welcome to the man of recaps this is the
matrix original trilogy keanu reeves is
thomas anderson who goes by the hacker
alias neo he's surfing the interwebs
with his dial up 56k modem when he gets
a mysterious message follow the white
rabbit alice in wonderland style he
follows the girl with the white rabbit
tattoo and here he meets a mysterious
woman trinity who long story short
invites neo to join her leatherclad
super hacker club their leader is
morpheus a man who can only speak in
deep mind-blowing one-liners he offers
neo the iconic choice take the blue pill
and go home now or take the red pill and
learn the truth about reality now you
should never take mystery pills from
strangers because things get weird but
not nearly as weird as when neo wakes up
in a sci-fi goo pod morpheus picks neo
up welcome to the real world that's
right the world we thought we lived in
is nothing but a computer simulation
called the matrix the real world
unfortunately is an apocalyptic
hellscape humans invented artificial
intelligence but the machines rebelled
and we went to war classic the machines
were all solar-powered so humanity
scorched the sky to block out the sun
but apparently the human body generates
a ton of electricity so the machines now
farm humans to be their batteries and
they created the matrix as an invisible
prison for our minds there's a prophecy
though about a messiah type figure
called the one and morpheus believes the
one is neo first things first though neo
needs some combat training he downloads
martial arts directly into his brain
which is why he famously says i know
kung fu morpheus is like show me and
these movies do have incredible super
sweet choreographed kung fu fights and
because they're in a computer program
they're allowed to bend the laws of
physics a little bit letting them pull
off some impossible stunts but the
matrix is a dangerous place because
anyone who's still plugged in can be
taken over by an agent agents are the
security programs that are stronger and
faster than any human could be but
that's why they hope neo is the one and
so it's time to jack into the matrix
where our crew all wears leather and
sunglasses you know to blend in neo has
to meet with the oracle who's got a
bunch of potential the ones here little
spoon bending kid lets neo in on his
secret there is no spoon oh mind blown
the oracle is a cookie baking grandma
type but she has bad news for neo he's
not the one on the way out neo sees the
same cat twice whoa deja vu deja vu
that's a glitch in the matrix our crews
walked into a trap and of course if you
die in the matrix you die in real life
soon an agent shows up and morpheus
fights him so new can escape but the
agent's just too strong our crew was
betrayed by one of their own this
douchebag cipher who made a deal with
the machines to put him back into the
matrix even though he knows it's not
real ignorance is bliss luckily though
their operator tank is able to zap him
with the laser gun and get neon trinity
out of there but morpheus is still
inside being interrogated by agent smith
who gives the famous speech humanity is
a virus so neo's like hey i'm not the
one but i think i can still save
morpheus but to do it we're gonna need
guns lots of guns this whole next scene
hits differently now that mass shootings
have become so tragically common in
america but still it's one of the
greatest action sequences ever as neo
and trinity bust in there for an epic
shootout yeah running up walls slow-mo
cartwheels ow but up on the roof an
agent is fast enough to dodge bullets
but when he shoots back at neo now neo's
fast enough to dodge bullets too epic
bullet time limbo skills long story
shortly rescue morpheus he and trinity
log off but before neo can agent smith's
here to stop him it's an epic showdown
agent smith has the upper hand but neo
pulls some awesome moves in the end
smith's got him time to die mr anderson
but my name is neo and out flips out of
there defeats agent smith but he doesn't
stay dead he can just possess the next
person and meanwhile in the real world
the squid machines have found their ship
they can't blow their emp while neo
still jacked in so it's a race against
time as neo hunts for a landline but
smith was ahead of him and oh shoots neo
multiple times he's definitely dead but
now trinity's like you can't be dead the
oracle told me i'd fall in love with the
one and i'm in love with you neo and it
works she's sleeping beauties and back
to life he rejects death and is now a
fully realized the one able to stop
bullets with his mind now fighting the
agents is trivially easy in fact he sees
the source code of the matrix and knows
how to jump in and delete agent smith so
he gets out in time they take out the
squid robot and the day is saved neo is
the one ready to win the war and also he
can fly now next up is the matrix
reloaded in the real world it's time to
visit the last human stronghold the
underground city of zion it's a cool
place where they like to throw retro
futuristic caveman techno raves now neo
is the one but it would be pretty boring
if he easily beat everyone so the agents
got some upgrades and they can still
have sweet fights he revisits the oracle
who's like i didn't technically lie to
you you weren't the one at the time but
now that he is the one he realizes she's
not human she's a computer program she's
like yeah you know it's just like people
there's good ones and bad ones i'm on
the side of humanity so she tells him
what to do next he needs to find the key
maker to access the matrix mainframe but
first neo gets a surprise visitor
because agent smith is back apparently
he didn't delete him he just freed him
from his old programming so now smith
can do whatever he wants and he's
learned a new trick he can now copy
himself so it's the epic multi-smith
fight neo seems to have things pretty
well in hand but more smith's keep
coming and pretty soon he gets out of
hand neo pieces out of their superman
style so now they need the keymaker
who's being held by a program called the
merivinjian whose vibe is a rich french
douchebag he doesn't want to give him up
but his wife's mad at him so she leads
him to the keymaker so now he has to
stick his white dreadlock ghost brothers
after them neo stays behind to fight the
rest of his gang and he can still stop
bullets super sweet so it's time for the
awesome chateau fight where they all
grab medieval weapons off the walls
meanwhile morpheus fighting the banshee
brothers but it turns into a big highway
car chase that quickly gets wild
morpheus has a dual katana vs suv and
somehow katana wins trinity grabs a
motorcycle going against the flow of
traffic morpheus fighting an agent on a
semi-truck in the end boom big crash but
neo flies in there just in time to save
him so the keymaker leads neo to the
secret mainframe door and inside it's a
room with a ton of tv screens and he
meets the architect of the matrix he's
very verbose ergo the anomaly inexorably
arrived but basically he explains that
the 1 is the result of a rounding error
0.0001 of people reject the matrix but
he drops a big truth bomb the machines
know about the one and have planned for
it the entire prophecy is just another
level of control right now the machines
are tunneling to zion with enough of an
army to wipe it out just like they've
done seven times before the real purpose
of the one isn't to win the war for
humanity but it's to be the first
members of a new zion and restart the
whole cycle but neo's having none of
this he's like yo screw you man i'll
take my chances meanwhile trinity is in
some trouble she was fighting an agent
and is falling to her death sunil flies
faster than ever and oh he catches her
unfortunately though she was hit and is
dying but now it's neo's time to save
her he reaches into her code and gives
her the handheld defibrillator whoa back
to life and the day is saved except of
course the day is not saved at all neal
fills them in that zion's about to be
destroyed and the prophecy is a lie and
right now there's a bigger problem when
the machines destroy their ship now
neo's the one powers only work inside
the matrix but now he can feel the
machines in the real world and oh he
stops them zaps them out he passes out
though and that's where matrix 2 ends so
now it's time for the epic conclusion in
the matrix revolutions which
unfortunately is just as bad as you
remember neo is still passed out
apparently his mind is trapped between
the matrix and the real world or
something i don't really know and so
like jack sparrow in pirates 3 our main
character spends the beginning of the
movie doing nothing by himself
eventually though our crew comes to
rescue him they got to make a deal with
the maravingian but trinity makes him an
offer he can't refuse and they're
reunited sonia goes to see the oracle
again and he's pretty mad she didn't
tell him about the prophecy being a lie
she's like sorry kid but i told you what
you needed to know at the time and you
gotta trust me things are different this
time we can break the cycle because
there's a new variable agent smith in
fact soon smith comes to see her and
he's become cartoonishly evil smashing
her cookies and now he turns the oracle
into a smith clone and it becomes the
super smith so our gang wants to go
defend zion but neo's like hey sorry the
fellowship has to break up i need to
metaphorically take the ring to mount
doom at the machine mainframe trinity's
going with him sam and frodo stick
together but there's a golem stow away
back and reloaded agent smith copied
himself onto one of the freed humans so
agent smith's got a physical body
creeping around in the real world but
now he's got neo right where he wants
him with know the one powers and so they
have a boring no powered real world
fight in the end neo gets blinded but
that's a good thing because now he can
see the code inside him or something
meanwhile the army of squiddies is
coming for zion and it's the actual cool
zion defense scene where humanity's got
these sweet machine gun mechs yeah
but in the end they're just too
outnumbered and things look bleak but
wait who's this flying in it's morpheus
with his ex-girlfriend jada pickett
smith they bust in there just in time to
set off their emp and take out all the
squids maybe we should have led with
that so zion is saved for all of five
minutes till reinforcements arrive so
humanity's last hope is neo and trinity
who make it to the machine mainframe
they have sort of a rough landing though
and trinity dies no resurrections this
time so neil go solo to see the machine
main brain like hey bud let's make a
deal agent smith's going to destroy both
worlds i can defeat him in exchange for
peace so they jack neo back into the
matrix where it has become fully
smithtown and so it's time for the final
showdown neo vs super smith at this
point though they can both fly so it's
an epic superman fight in theory it's an
awesome aerial kung fu battle dragon
ball z style but unfortunately it didn't
turn out that good it's kind of a bland
cgi mess in the end though agent smith
is going to win but neo refuses to give
up i've got free will and i choose to
keep fighting so smith copies himself
onto neo and it looks like smith has won
but he doesn't know neo's plugged into
the mainframe who's now able to like
delete him for real and boom all the
smiths exploded neo has finally gone
full jesus sacrificed himself to save
humanity the machines keep their promise
they leave zion and inside the matrix
it's the dawning of a new era of
peaceful coexistence between machines
and humans and that's where the original
matrix trilogy comes to an end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you loved
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member